Wir befinden uns hier in Korneugburg und wir
trainieren heute in
Greifenstein am Kraftwerk.
Ausgangslage ist folgende: Das Kraftwerk
wurde von terroristischen
Zellen in Besitz genommen und unsere
Aufgabe ist es jetzt, das
Kraftwerk wieder zurückzugewinnen.
Oft der schnellste und einfachste Weg,
sich an der Grenze nähern,
ist die Wasserstraße.
Deshalb benutzen wir
die Wasserstraße in dem Fall.
Die größte Hürde, ein Kraftwerk zu nehmen, ist die große Höhe.
Wir haben da bis zu zwölf, fast 15 Meter
zu überwinden, um vom Wasser
auf das Kraftwerk zu kommen.
Um diese großen Höhen eines Kraftwerks
zu überwinden, haben wir verschiedene
Möglichkeiten bzw Geräte.
Wir benutzen da verschiedene Leitersysteme.
Wir haben daher das Hook and Bowl system.
Das ist sehr lange eine lange Stange mit
den Haken, wo eine Strickleiter befestigt
ist und wir versuchen dann die
Leiter, die Strickleiter, und den Haken so
hoch wie möglich zu setzen bzw auch
strategisch
auf einen guten Platz zu positionieren und
gewinnen den dann direkt aus dem
Wasser aus von einem Schlauchboot.
Eine zusätzliche Hürde ist natürlich das
ganze Gerät oder das Zusatzgerät, das wir
mit uns haben und brauchen,
um den Auftrag zu erfüllen.
Es kann sein Sprengstoff, das kann sein,
Medics (Sanitäter), aber auch Einsatzhunde,
die wir dann vor Ort brauchen, wenn
wir im Kraftwerk sind.
Es könnte sein, Zugriffshunde
Sprengstoff- oder Spürhunde.
Um die nach oben zu bringen,
die können natürlich nicht
selber die Leiter raufklettern,
wird das ganze recht technisch und wir
behelfen uns da ganz normalen alpinen
Hilfsmitteln, um das zu bewerkstelligen.
Selbst für den Hund ist es
erst gar nicht so einfach.
Der braucht ja jetzt nicht aktiv etwas
dazu beitragen, weil er eben nicht
klettern kann und dann
wird er hinaufgezogen.
Aber der Hund soll natürlich oben
arbeiten können und einsatzbereit sein.
Das heißt, er muss sich an diese Situation
gewöhnen, an das Wasser gewöhnen, das Boot
gewöhnen und daran gewöhnen, dass er jetzt
einen langen Strick einfach auf
hohe Mauer rauf gezogen wird.
Je öfter man das macht mit dem
Hund, desto besser geht das.
Nach einer Zeit hat er sich daran
gewöhnt und der Hund ist dann,
wenn wir oben angekommen sind, einsatzbereit.
Das Kraftwerk ist natürlich ein
komplexes Objekt.
Das Kraftwerk besteht aus
verschiedenen Gebäuden,
Staumauer, großen Toren, Schleusen,
Bürogebäuden usw.
Das heißt, wir versuchen natürlich,
bevor wir jetzt ein Kraftwerk nehmen,
dass wir uns darüber Gedanken machen....
Wir versuchen die Pläne anzuschauen und
versuchen uns darauf vorzubereiten,
auf die verschiedenen Gegebenheiten.
Teilweise schaut es in einem Kraftwerk aus
wie in einer Bunkeranlage und
teilweise schaut es aus wie in einem super hi-tech Office
wir haben da verschiedene
Schwierigkeiten, verschiedene Umstände
und müssen natürlich darauf reagieren.
Die Stärke des Jagdkommandos, die
Schnelligkeit,
Überraschung und Schlagkraft.
Das ist wesentlich, um Objekt
schnell und effektiv zu nehmen.
Was wir nicht können, ist es, Objekte
über längere Zeit zu halten.
Deshalb wird, nachdem wir das Objekt
genommen haben, dieses Kraftwerk
in dem Fall der Exekutive oder den anderen
Truppenkörper des österreichischen
Bundesheeres übergeben.